[Music]
and
a
[Music]
he
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute but let's do it in a way that
makes the snowflakes heads explode let
me be clear before this podcast begins
we are loud loud proud and do not give a
[Music]
[__] this is the Tony Michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not Liberty
you [__] eating [__] ah the smell of
freedom of speech this is the Tony
Michaels podcast and this is Tony
Michaels hey Tony [__]
[Music]
them he's found down it up and truck it
we going to do what they say can't be
done or some [__] I don't know they
apparently a bunch of pedophiles
claiming to be a trucker's Convoy went
to a children's Christian Camp I'm not
I'm not making that [__] up
I would never make anything up I'm
serious a bunch of pedophiles disguise
is a trucker Convoy is going to a
children's Christian Camp they're not
going to the
Border they went to a that let me say it
again a bunch of
pedophiles disguised as a trucker
Convoy went to a children's Christian
Camp in Texas not the
Border and they got a
cross and they're they're they're doing
Ted nent who loves to have sex with
13-year-olds apparently I don't I mean I
people are saying that Ted nett loves
big dildos and he loves little girls and
Sarah Palin showed up at this Christian
children's camp where the pedophile
Convoy has went down to Texas and they
showed up L Laur Laura what's her name
not Laura lomer the other Laura Laura
Laura that's it Laura Logan that's what
it is I knew it was LL Laura Logan Lara
Laura lumer I don't [__] I don't know
these people are all [__] nuts
they're crazy Laura lomer follows me on
Twitter and Lara Logan attacked me on
Twitter because I called Andy no a Nazi
because Andy no is is a Nazi I'm not
kidding you that happened she attacked
me with some word salad with some weird
cleavage word salad have you ever
noticed that Laura Logan always she's
always got
her I don't know I don't know maybe I I
think I think I think it's beautiful if
you want to know the honest truth but
she's a
[Applause]
nutbag but that's the story that's the
story um the Maga has a pedophile
problem they had to run off all the
pedophiles from the trucker Convoy uh
and people are really mad about it
people are really mad that the
pedophiles are trying to grip
in manga I'm like what the [__] where
the [__] are you people been you're scar
you're you're just now figuring out that
pedophiles and
chomos are grifting and
MAA are you serious that's this is news
to
you Donald Donald Trump best friends
with Jeffrey Epstein for all them years
come on man are you serious you really
you really you're surprised by this do
you remember Roy Moore in Alabama do you
remember Roy Moore he ran for Senate
Alabama this guy was a [__]
weirdo apparently he would go to the
malls the mall in Alabama to try to pick
up on
teenagers when he was like in his
30s he would go to the mall to pray on
children he's a republican in Alabama
and he lost in Alabama to Doug Jones
in the special
election and Trump endorsed him Roy
Moore the pedopile the
chomo the I go to malls to prey on
children to try to [__] them that Roy
Moore and you're just now surprised that
MAA has a pedophile problem have you
ever heard of Matt gats have you ever
heard of this
guy the the vinmo vigilant PL Matt
gats paying for drugs and sex for
underage girl showing this is not out of
my mouth this is out of Mark Wayne
mullen's mouth he's United States
Senator Republican United States senator
in Oklahoma stating that Matt Gat showed
him underage porn on the house
floor people are saying that MAA has a
pedophile
problem
[__] time after time after time we see
on the internet of these
pastors and these self-righteous Trump
hat wearing [__] Cheeto humping [__]
nuggets being arrested for having child
porn or molesting or sexually assaulting
a young a young child Time and Time and
Time and Time and Time Again at some
[__] white Christian nationalist or
some goddamn manga Trump
supporter come on man and you're just
now maa's like Whoa We got a pedophile
problem I thought we were I thought we
were fighting the blood sucking cabal we
are the you're the baddies
yes yes you are the
baddies it's been like that for a long
time folks we've been trying to [__]
point this [__] out to you
people and you're just like no q andon
and stuff Facebook said that
those de
Democrats I'm dead serious a bunch of
pedophiles are pretending to be a
trucker's Convoy to go secure the
Border I'm guessing at the porch of
Entry at the Southwest border of
terrorism that's what I think I think
that's where they're
going but they ended not going to that
border they ended up going to a CH
listen the pedophiles went to a
children's Christian
Camp that's what
happened now a lot of people are asking
about Bon head of the week we do not
have bone head we normally have boneh
head of the week on Friday I know that's
the bad news here at the Tony Michaels
podcast today Gabe Sanchez couldn't join
me for bone end of the week
today so I had to make an executive
decision do we want to do bonehead
without Gabe which I don't think
bonehead is very good without get you
just want to see me do bonehead number
one we wouldn't have the awesome
Graphics so that would suck and then we
wouldn't have the guy with the last name
Sanchez so we're just gonna have to wait
until next week to do a boneh head of
the week I promise though I promise
we'll get bonehead of the weekend at
some point so no Bon of the week today
but I do have a special treat for you if
we get time for this today yeah there's
no Gabe today Gabe is busy Gabe has
something that he's doing we're not
going to do bonee head of the week with
the guy with the last name Sanchez did
you know that's his that's his brain job
bonee head of the week I know people are
upset I know don't leave though don't go
anywhere it's gonna be a good goddamn
show we're gonna mock the [__] out of
the one truck Convoy literally there's
there's only one semi- truck these
aren't actual truckers they're just a
bunch of pedophiles cosplaying as
truckers I
guess I don't know what you want from
me
I report you
decide I'm going to show you videos of
them chasing off pedophiles I'm not
[__] you there is f they are live
streaming themselves chasing off the
maganga
pedophiles and then there's one woman
this video is going viral that I'm gonna
show you she's so [__] pissed off and
she's so upset that she's been grifted
I'm like oh my God finally finally these
[__] brainless idiots are waking up
the brain cells are are rubbing together
the brain cells are CL clanking I found
it out the hard
way they're clanking
together and they're they're they're
they're creating energy enough to maybe
create a half a thought to know that
they've they've been being grifted this
entire [__]
time
oh some people are saying we should have
Cliff sector Shor on more often I mean
we're going to have him we were doing
every two weeks now we're going to do
every week it's gonna be on I'm trying
to get AP on today too um ap's got some
news and some reporting about the Convoy
she's been watching all this stuff um
and she she's actually seen and been
within proximity as some of these Convoy
pedophiles so maybe we'll get a report
from AP on the ground you guys know her
as Anarchy princess I think I'm just
gonna call her AP here just say AP AP
and princess you're already facing
charges
so um when we when we get to that point
uh if she can get free and we can get a
report from what she's been seeing from
the pedophile
Convoy then we'll we'll have um AP on
someone's asking what about Hal Sparks
Hal spark Hal Sparks has been on the
show I've been on Hal show too I
actually interviewed Hal Sparks I think
a couple times um for the January 6
select hearing I was on I was on John
Stuttering John M melendez's show with
Hal a couple times that's how me and
Cliff first
met H I went on um stering John show
when Cliff was on there and he was like
who the [__] is this guy this guy's
nuts and he immediately imely
immediately followed me on Twitter and
started sending me a message like you're
[__] nuts I love it
so
um everyone wants me to keep clowning
the Convoy oh we're gonna clown the
Convoy today today is a special Friday
we're going to make it a clown a clown
car clown car Friday where we uh we mock
the the pedophile Convoy um again I'm
gonna show you the videos this is not
this is not me making that [__] up this
is not me making that [__] up up um Shaz
Shaz Shaz is finally caught on um here
Shaz is Shaz and The Shard Army finally
caught on that I was arrested and I
wasn't arrested actually I I selfs
surrendered Chez you should go you
should go look it up a little better
before you ask questions about my my
history with the sticky
Bandits you should really you should
really go look it up before you start
asking questions it's all over the
Internet you little [__] like you
doxed me and thought it was cool and oh
it'll get Tony to shut up it only me
made me scream louder dummy and the
entire audience knows I've been to
federal prison so if they're if they're
not down with that and they're not okay
with that then they they have not been
listening and the audience probably
doesn't care I would imagine um you know
come on get it
together I bet there's many members of
the audience that uh have been arrested
too
so and have been in lockup but I've
never actually been arrested Shez I've
never actually been arrested it's always
selfs surrender I selfs surrendered
because I'm not a [__] a crazy
criminal that does crazy [__] so you
know that's how it
happens I'm glad things worked out well
for you Tony they did work out well for
me buddy I mean you're you're here every
[__] day listening to my to me dummy
what are you talking about oh
[__] um Cynthia asked a question and
people are saying this that Chaz were
you arrested for gay
[Laughter]
porn oh we're gonna have fun this Friday
since we have bon of the week we're
gonna go off the rails today we're gonna
have fun I got banned the other day on
Facebook uh Shaz that was probably you
I'm I'm are your one of your shart Army
lieutenants that reported the video um
the good news is you [__] uh we won the
appeal um so I'm not I'm not banned on
Facebook we can broadcast from Facebook
Facebook told whoever reported the video
to go [__] themselves which you know I'm
kind of surprised I'm actually surprised
by that now you saw in real time me get
banned silenced we're silenced oh
cancelled and you notice that I wasn't
broken up at all about it I was actually
laughing about it and we were talking
about this this morning in the producers
Corner because you know Derek the meme
General with the help of skip the the
the clipmaster they've been doing such a
great job over on the YouTube channel
all right skip M makes these real
ominous bum bum bum and funny videos too
to make points and Derek does such a
good job of pulling clips that we put on
the show and ones that I can't get on
the show to show you guys here on the
YouTube channel so make sure that you're
going watching those shorts and those
clips um because some of that stuff I
can't I don't have time to show on the
show I don't have time to put it in um
and and Skip does a ton of videos that
I'm not I don't have time to put in
either so you guys should really go
check out all those shorts and all those
clips on the YouTube channel and we're
gonna try we try to put them on Facebook
and I try to get them on Instagram and
uh Twitter xchan you know over there um
because you can put anything over there
but you should go watch those videos and
you should appreciate their their effort
because they're putting in a ton of
effort they're doing a ton of work and
those videos are awesome they're doing
such a great job of getting this
information in front of you so that you
can that you can comment under the
comments of the shart Army because The
Shard Armory man they get in there like
oh Trump
2024 and you
know so a lot of those clips have been
blowing up on the YouTube channel so I
want to thank the audience for watching
those watching ing those shorts and
paying attention to those clips um
having your notifications on so you get
to see the hard work that everyone here
is doing behind the scenes but I want to
tell you that what we're g to try to do
is we're g to try to to use every single
tool we can to Mock and use [__] with
these fascists right rather it's the the
pedophiles Convoy or it's MAA or whoever
whoever the target is to [__] with the
sh Chazz and the shart Army whoever the
[__] it is that we're [__] with what
we want to try to do is we want to try
to put these videos at your disposal
because don't think you can't share [__]
and you can't steal stuff from me steal
it Go spread that [__] around on the
internet like it's [__] herpes okay
we need to give maganga our VD of Truth
you got it that's what we got to do so
here's here's what I want you to do and
I know some people may not like Discord
or want to learn how to use Discord but
what we're going to be doing is we're
going to be posting all that content in
Discord for you to download so you can
go post that content that video or that
Meme on your social media account right
so we're gonna we're gonna have a full
operation with the meme Legion in the
rat Army over on Discord so that you
guys can grab that content and go put it
on your social media channels I mean you
can like retweet me and all that kind of
stuff if you want and comment and all
that kind of stuff that that creates
engagement right and really that the
purpose is is to get people like Shaz in
the shark army in the comments really
[__] hammering the keyboard you know
what I mean because the more they Hammer
they don't understand this but because
they're [__] dumb but they they
Hammer the keyboard and like oh Tony's a
commi or whatever the [__] they're
saying Trump 2024 even though he's gonna
lose and he lost last
time just post it because we want them
to comment because it it it amplifies it
it pushes it it pushes it out into the
algorithm was like man this shit's
really really getting attention so let's
send it to more people so that that's
what you should do you should go grab
this content and you should use it to
the best of your ability to cause
[__] right that's what we're trying
to do anyways we're trying to win this
goddamn election and the best way we can
do that is to get them [__] pissed
off because it's working I mean the
Taylor Swift sop is in full swing that's
[__] working beautifully oh my God
they are digging they are digging the
grave as deep as they possibly can dig
this grave about the Border crisis the
crisis at the B I mean they sent [__]
pedophiles down in a convoy to a
children's Christian Camp they they sent
pedophiles to a children's Christian
Camp in Texas not to the border huh I
wonder what the pedophiles are doing
going to a children's Christian Camp I
don't know you figure that out but don't
waste time to go spread this [__] around
the
internet don't don't waste any time
spreading this [__] around the [__]
internet we ain't got time to waste here
so make sure you're joining the Discord
let me show you how to do that let me
give you quick steps just go to the Tony
michaels.com you just go to the Tony
michaels.com hit the Subscribe button at
the top and then pan on down and click
join the Discord server right here
memberships join the Discord server
that's where you will find all the memes
and the videos and it will be files that
you can download and then you can use to
go create [__] by mocking these son
of a [__] rather it's a great one of
the one of the great ominous bum bum bum
bum clips that skip makes or one of the
funny ones that he makes the one the
other day
were where they're punching each other
in the
balls because Republicans I mean you
know they step on rakes they're jump air
traps and they're getting they're
punching themselves in the balls right
that's all they're doing these days it's
it's like a Pastime for them it's a
hobby you know bear trap stepping right
instead of the long jump It's the bear
trap jump um so they're doing that
themselves but you have to point this
stuff out you have to go grab that stuff
and go [__] it out on the internet
go spread it around like herpes and I
know that's not the
most glorious way to put it but it
entertains you you're like Jesus
Christ give the internet the VD of Truth
you goddamn right that's what we should
do so make sure make sure you go join
the Discord again you can go to Theon
michaels.com just pan on down to Discord
hit the hit the link make sure you
verify when you go in there you just got
to click the little green check mark and
we'll get you verifi IED um you know
just hanging there I think it's like a
48 or 72 hour period that you're kind of
a visitor until someone clicks oh yeah
they're good they're good to go um but
if you click that button we'll get you
verified and everything will be will be
a okay because we know you're you're an
actual human in there and that's where
the rat Army in the mean Legion meets
you see is on Discord and the reason why
the reason why it's so important that we
do it there is because that's kind of
our own little Gathering Spot you know
it's our own little town that we've
created our town of [__] [__]
Ville as as it may be
known feryville in the state of mockery
okay now when you go there you're G
there's a lot of stuff to do you got the
book club you can post pictures you can
communicate with people like-minded
people you can make friends
there and there's a lot of people that
are members on our Discord you can talk
to them and it's like a
247 shitalking feed right but what I
want you to understand is there there's
weapons that you can use in there for
your democracy to engage people for The
Ballot Box that's the most important
thing to understand that we must drive
this vote and it's important that we do
it in the correct way because Americans
are going to vote against stuff okay
that's just what Americans are going to
do they're gonna vote against stuff
Americans get pissed off against things
that's the American way I mean in Jesus
Christ that's how we were started we
were like no we don't want Theocratic
monarchy [__] you and now they're like
yeah we want a Theocratic monarchy again
and we're like no [__] you again and
forever you know what I mean so so you
just gotta you gotta have your wits
about you um when you're when you're
spreading [__] around the internet but
sometimes you got to go where the
getting's good right you're not going to
go to a safe space like our Discord and
punch a lot of Nazis right that's where
you're going to get the you're going to
get the boxing gloves to go out into the
world and do a little bit of you know
swinging towards these fascist right and
that's what you really want to look for
on the social media and that's kind of
the thing I want to do today in Lou that
we're not going to have bonehead is I'm
going to show you not only how to go
into Discord and grab that stuff right
because that's where you can get some
really good stuff um to to have with you
when you're out there on social media
and you see some uh member of the shart
Army typing in some crazy ass [__] you
might just have a video to or M to Handy
on your phone saved on your phone so you
could drop that [__] for him and just
drop some truth in the comment section
and what it'll do is it'll
engage that [__] eater it'll piss him
off oh my God it'll [__] make them
infuriated they won't stop pounding the
keyboard what you're doing is you're
just distracting them right you're just
distracting them for a day or two trust
me they will keep commenting as long as
you keep going they will keep why do you
think Shaz is here every day posting
hundreds of comments every because I
don't shut up so he comes here every day
and he has to post and I mean he's paid
to post by by Putin right he's paid to
post by he's paid to post by Putin but
he's got to come and he's got to [__]
put those comments in because Tony won't
shut the [__] up you can do the same
thing to all these [__] eaters and the
beautiful thing is is you just have all
this this whole like catalog or Library
full of [__] to just dump in these
comment sections to [__] with them and
I'm going to show you today how to make
your own [__] too so you can go you
can go steal the [__] right you can
go steal the [__] which you should
you should totally 100% steal all the
[__] you can from our Discord and
from me and if anyone blam you for
stealing [__] you just blame me just
tell them Tony said that's all you got
to do and just say w Tony Tony told us
to spread this around the
internet [__] them okay so but I'm GNA
show you today um and it's a little it's
going to be a little workshop here on
the show uh how to create some Donald
Trump memes anything that comes to your
mind you can really create we're g to be
artists today that's right I'm going to
turn you into meme artist into the meme
Legend and you guys are going to take
those memes and you're going to go
spread around the internet but you're
also going to share them with all the
other all the other troops in the rat
Army that are just causing all kinds of
[__] and mockery all over the
Internet so today's a special day it's a
special Friday we don't have bone in of
the week because we don't have Gabe
Sanchez but we're going to Workshop a
little bit we're going to Workshop our
way into winning our democracy so you're
going to want to stay tight today you're
not going to want to leave and we're
going to mock the trucker Convoy I'm
going to show you these videos of
them oh my God I'm gonna show you video
of them trying to chase off
pedophiles they got a huge [__]
pedophile and grifter problem one of
them they put him up on stage they put
him up on stage they put Ted nent up on
stage I think didn't he didn't he marry
a 13-year-old or something [__] I don't
know I don't know Ted nent and Sarah
Palin boy you couldn't get any more
irrelevant than that I guess I guess Kid
Rock Kid Rock must have um been playing
some bar somewhere
huh oh my God oh my God that's the way
it goes that's the way the cookie
crumbles but I'm glad you joined me
every single weekday Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
two full hours of the Tony Michaels
podcast your home of [__] here
broadcasting live from the antifa
corporate headquarters in Kami Falls
Missouri we will cause the [__] that
will save our democracy from the cousin
[__] fascist and the the pedophile
Convoy so don't go anywhere we'll be
right back right after this right right
after this check this out I'm telling
you with the Convoy thing you're going
to watch to watch this
commercial what the [__] is wrong with
you people it's a rhetorical question at
[Music]
best we'll be right back on the Tony
Michaels
[Music]
podcast letters from the trucker
Convoy de's Tammy by the time we reach
DC weight was 50 strong in number some
patriots ran out of gas along the way
we got plenty of slim gems
skull near run out Natty light hope it
don't rain tomorrow so we can Circle the
city again here's Bob dear Bob I'm
fixing to send you some more of them
Doritos you like the red bag not the
little looking blue one in your absence
I discovered a rash on my neck and no it
ain't no hickey and I even seen my
cousin Brody in
ages stay strong wipe your ass at least
once a day yours T
me [__] them [__] [__] them [__] [__]
them [__] we're back to the Tony
Michaels
[Music]
podcast welcome back to the
show boy that you thought oh man there's
no way Tony Can Play that video forever
eventually that video will not be
relevant ah Trucker's Convoy is back
[__] and it's more pedo than ever
apparently they didn't know that there
was pedophiles that's [__] that's
[__]
weird I have a great great announcement
right now this is a very important
announcement our mod Jin Jim Williams
moderator for a long time Jim Williams
has a birthday today happy birthday to
you happy birthday birthday to you happy
birthday Jim everyone give Jim a happy
birthday in the comments great moderator
we love having him here um and we we we
appreciate Jim every single day coming
here and hanging out with us being a mod
welcoming everyone into the group Jim is
a great mod and all of our moderators
are great make sure you thank them and
welcome them and tell them hi tell them
goodbye and thank them for all the work
they do so happy birthday Jim and we
appreciate we appreciate you being here
and we appreciate having you on the Tony
Michael's podcast it is a privilege to
have you as a moderator so thanks Jim oh
man these these these
truckers they're not truckers they're
not [__] truckers they're in like
minivans and Honda Civics and [__]
there's one truck there's one [__]
semi TR one
one they're all cosplaying all these
pedophiles are cosplaying to be
truckers what do you think this manga
movement is I've been telling you for a
long time that that is the actual big
lie that's the actual big
lie there is no support for Trump
amongst normal [__] people that have
enough brain cells to rub
together it's not a big support yes like
crystal said they're
larpers they're laring they couldn't
even drive a [__] semi if they
tried [__] [__]
holes good [__] god what is wrong
with you goddamn people of course
they're not
truckers but
apparently the uh the U truckers Convoy
people discovered that MAA has a
pedophile
problem no h no M's got a pedopile
problem no [__] Sherlock well here is
here's this guy I don't know who the
[__] this guy is and I really don't know
who this pedo is in this car but
apparently this guy knows that this guy
is part of the pedophile Convoy right
and they're cosplaying to be truckers so
that they can go to the children's
Christian
Camp that's a real F I'm going to show
you the [__] children's Christian
Camp that they're at where Ted nent the
guy who likes to marry and [__] children
I don't know that's what people say
didn't aren't they didn't didn't he
marry a 13-y old girl or some [__] Ted
Nan what was Kid Rock drinking too much
Bud Light he couldn't show up I don't
know Sarah Palin was there so that
speaks wildly of how unpopular their
pedophile Convoy
is but here it is um there trying to
smoke out all the pedophiles in their
movement and so here watch this and then
why are you even going to try to insert
yourself you know we we are the dude
that come over here first Master
grifter that
[__] Master
grifter oh my [__] god so wait a
second wait a second there are people in
the pedophile Convoy and their names
their internet handles are Master
grifter oh my God these people are
[__]
wild this this is the master race
folks this these are the people who
claim they're gonna they're going to fix
all our problems they can't even they
can't even get rid of the pedophiles and
their
movement
okay
okay but they also they also have people
with the names Master grifter Deedra
says Big D no I don't I don't think it's
big D I think it's Little D I
think little Little D um let's
watch he's coming over here getting on
your ass well he's excused pedophiles
his own what he calls his brother Marcus
copac okay yeah very interesting and you
know and the why the [__] are you even
coming here man I mean why you know
everybody knows that on paper you are a
pedophile what on paper why why are they
why are they so quick to half-handed
excuse this [__] you know what I'm
saying I mean I know this guy's trying
to make a point and this guy's trying to
get the pedophiles out of the pedophile
Convoy but that's kind of I mean dude
there they didn't go to the Border they
went to a children's Christian Camp what
what what what else did you need to know
about them and who the [__] they want to
commit crimes on huh what more did you
have to
know when the pedophile Convoy came down
to a children's Christian Camp not the
Border but this guy's like on paper on p
on on paper what do you mean on paper
you either are or you aren't what the
[__] does that mean on paper I guess it
I guess it means I guess it means
that he's been convicted so on paper
it's like I don't know is he saying you
have to carry a card around because you
know I mean generally speaking when you
commit certain kind of crimes you gotta
let your neighbors
know maybe uh Cynthia R says is this a
skit I mean it might be they may just
been doing they were live streaming this
[__] right they're like yeah we're going
to go save the country we're going to go
down to the Border not really the Border
we're we're going to go to a children's
Christian Camp and we're going to make
sure pedophiles come with us to the
children's Christian
Camp and they were live streaming this
[__] keep going keep going
there pedophile Hunter and I'll be hon I
don't really give a [__] about I'm not
part of this I'm not part of
this he's not well I mean you don't want
to be part of it now I mean who would
who would want to be a part of a convoy
that isn't a convoy it has one semi and
a couple minivans with a bunch of
pedophiles in it right who wants to be a
part of that I mean other than a bunch
of [__] pedophiles right a bunch of
[__] weirdos and
pedophiles oh
man someone says you are now buddy BW
rocks like yeah you're you're in this
now
[__] okay keep going I'm a Texan I live
about four and a half hours away from
here down here especially when figured
out your ass was
here why why why are you even come in
here
man I'm serious this guy's riding in a
he's riding dirty in a
minivan look at this piece of [__] this
hunk of [__] this is the trucker's
Convoy right here this is the pedophiles
Convoy Drive I mean you couldn't get
more creepier I mean I guess you could
like a white panoan you know what I mean
what the [__] got a wider angle Mike
asked me if I've got a wider angle dude
I'm just playing the video off the
internet you act you do you do you
people think that I send these cameras
out just for this show is that what you
think I mean that'd be cool if you think
that no I just go find this [__] and
report back to you what the hell's going
on and and give you an idea how to
properly mock these [__] idiots
because you know this is a serious thing
in that I can't believe that there is a
person running for president that this
is part of his [__] political
movement and the Republican party is
okay with it like that's really the
[__] thing you got to think about
here is that maanga has a pedophile
problem and it's not surprising because
their cult leader kind of seems like a
pedophile I mean he always talked about
[__] young girls he talked to to
Howard Stern about going into dressing
rooms at at Teen Miss Teen America where
he could go watch underage girls get
undressed because people like him can do
that oh they're so beautiful he would
talking about that he talked about how a
a a strange a stranger a little girl on
an elev escalator one time how he was
gonna marry
her he talked about [__] his own
daughter he talked about [__] his own
daughter and we are supposed to stand
around and be surprised that m has a
pedophile
problem come on
man all right keep going you Cheetoh
humping [__]
nugget he just told
you
because of
people that has to do with more
pedophiles like
you I can't help it I can't I
can't oh my God now I want to make this
really [__] clear that both these
[__] Bone Heads right there both
these [__] Bon heads right here 100%
are full on make America great again
type
[__]
okay 100% full on you can hear the lady
in the background sucking on her goddamn
Vape
pin we come here to hunt the
pedophiles cuz it to pedopile
comboy Shaz none of these people are
truckers you dumb
[__] that's the problem that you have
here man is that you believe this stupid
that's the problem that's the problem is
you believe this stupid [__] lie that
somehow these people are truckers none
of these people are truckers none of
them none of them are truckers they're
not they don't have trucks they got one
semiu in the whole [__] Convoy and
it's a bunch of pedophiles man they're
hanging out with a bunch of pedopiles I
don't know if you were here the other
day when AP was talking about
this but she said the same thing then
about the trucker trucker Convoy and a
20 in DC the one that I made the video
about that I made that I make fun of
that one that was a pedophile convoy too
and when you're on the side of the
trucker's Convoy shz you're on the side
of
pedophiles you know you know the way
that you demonize the lgbtq
community how you demonize them maybe
you should wake the [__] up rub a couple
brain cells together stop being such a
goddamn stupid bigot and understand that
you would be one of the first one they
kill if they take power yeah that's
right you would be one of the first ones
I know you probably got a lot of
skeletons in your closet
you would be one of the first ones the
fascists would get rid of because you
were a good soldier but they don't need
you anymore they've won now they got
power you're supporting
pedophiles known pedophiles even even
the people who are
cosplaying and laring as truckers know
that they got a pedophile problem
okay they know they got a pedophile
problem
so these none of these people are
truckers my friend that's your delusion
that's the lie you're believing but keep
going with the pedophile on pedophile
action here because I'm sure that's what
this is pedophile on pedophile
action so you didn't come here to
support the cause then no I support the
cause I just I just I just I'm just not
in behind this right here support the
cause the cause for a bunch of
pedophiles to go to the children's
Christian Camp not to the Border cuz
they didn't go to the Border they were
announcing on bullhorns they were
telling everyone in this one truck
Convoy that they were not going to go to
the Border we're not going to the Border
we're not going to the Border we're not
going to the border right by the way
we're not going to the Border we're
going to go to a children's Christian
Camp you know what I
mean make good use of our
[Laughter]
time that's what they were announcing
they were never going to go to the
Border okay I'm not behind be because of
a lot of some of the characters that are
in this thing okay that's that's the
reason why okay what I'm here well
originally came here because I believed
in the cause and it
wasn't what the people of the cause was
all about I know brother but you got to
understand man when you're a known
convicted
pedophile you don't have any business
being around any of this man there's
there's children
pedopile now they're GNA stand and argue
what the definition of a pedophile
is oh my God oh my
God and you know what you know it's so
stupid you know it's so stupid this
morning the [__] media is talking
about is talking about how the numbers
are bad in Michigan for
Biden that's right they're like oh
Muslims in Michigan aren't going to vote
for Biden because Biden isn't gonna
invade Israel and take over a sovereign
country and create a ceasefire or some
dumb
[__] I show yesterday the [__]
headline of the
story was was was the [__] numbers
that they T the
polls it looks like like we're going to
get AP on the show here and I'm going to
ask her if she kind of knows these
pedophiles come on get it together that
are um that are here so maybe she's got
her cowboy cowbell and her whistle but
she's going to be joining us soon it
seems like so hang tight don't go
anywhere um but the media this morning
is talking about because all the number
all their fake ass stupid polls that
they want you to pay attention to that
Trump's winning all the time all of a
sudden those polls were saying that
Biden was winning so now they're like no
no Biden's good lose actually even
though that he's going he's going to
lose actually because
uh because Muslims and young people
they're mad at
him when really you should be paying
attention to I don't know MAA and a
bunch of Republicans supporting a
pedophile's convoy I would say that
would probably be a thing that you'd
want to pay attention to why are they
supporting a a a on truck pedophile
Convoy why are they doing that why why
is Ted well I know why Ted Nan's going
to the children's Christian
Camp but I don't know why these other
folks are showing up there there's
apparently Republican establishment but
I have someone on the line here that
understands this one truck pedophile
Convoy and I think she'll give us some
insight I think she's I think she's
actually um been within proximity of
some of these these
miscreant um that had that decided it
would be a good idea to go down a good
idea for pedophiles to go down to a
children's Christian Camp in Texas not
the border so we have AP on the line AP
I'm so glad you joined us how are you
I'm great how are you I'm doing
fantastic I'm so glad you were joining
us today I know this was kind of in prop
too um but I know you know some of these
folks so do you got do you know this guy
have you met this guy in this video here
in this van yeah I actually I want to
talk about this because this um um this
video is getting a lot of traction and
it is there's a lot of context to that
one yeah so do you do you know that do
you know the guy in the in the in the
minivan in the weird ass looking minivan
with the weird mustache who who at this
point in the video he's he's debating
the um the pedophile Hunter here what
the definition of a pedophile is so when
you're starting when you're starting to
have a debate about what the definition
is you're a pedop
F yeah this is a bad one so okay so like
I said the other day there was another
Convoy right so there was at least three
confirmed pedophiles involved in that
earlier Convoy this guy is one of them
he has a YouTube channel that um he goes
by Outlaw Ministries his name is
Brian um I don't know if I should say
his name here but I don't give a [__]
you can say his name ran junle I believe
is what it is he is on the sex offender
offender registry but anyway he got
kicked out of the one the Convoy in
so the woman that's yelling at him was
also part of the first Convoy and she's
the one behind the camera is that is
that right okay yeah so she um obviously
has a problem with pedophiles as we all
do so she's kind of made it her life
mission to to go after these pedophiles
so to speak that she's familiar with so
there you know she hasn't seen this guy
that um Outlaw Ministry guys since the
last Convoy and he got kicked out but
there was another one that she was very
familiar with that you know she was kind
of doing the same thing for so
um how do I even begin with this so he
this man um when he was 17 years old
sexually assaulted an 8-year-old old I
don't really want to get very specific
about it but it was a relative and um
like I said he's on the sex offender
registry and so now he has decided to
show back up with this new Convoy in
Texas and the group confronted him
immediately when he got there um before
the woman her name is actually Lori but
before Lori confronts him another group
or another a couple people from the
group too and they tell him he's not
welcome but the police won't kick him
out because it's public property so this
guy has already been confronted and now
he's sitting there on his live stream
just making excuses he's just he's just
the victim and his story is has changed
so many times like first he was 15 he
was 14 the the girl was 11 she was all
these different ages um but it's all out
there the facts are out there he's been
convicted and you know like I said he's
on industry so that those individuals
from the Convoy they confront him and
then he just stays in his car like not
only is he is it's not just a parking
lot but that's actually um I forget what
they call it it's like a complex like a
sports complex so you can see like the
soccer go over there in the background
and there's field around yeah so there's
a playground there's children as as the
woman Lori pulls up because she live
streams it too you can see kids playing
on those parks and stuff so he gets
confronted by the the men from the group
and then continues to sit in his car
talking to his live stream for hours and
there's hundreds of people in that live
stream just telling him he's disgusting
and to leave and he's making all these
problems and he has all these excuses
and he's the victim blah blah blah so he
sits there forever and finally Lori
rolls up Lori was part of the old Convoy
is not part of this new Convoy she's
protesting it um she is she with this
guy
here yeah that's her boyfriend okay all
right he's actually a proud
boy I I like I like that we have proud
boys fighting pedophiles this is like
this is like the best Nazi punching Nazi
party that I've ever seen like I'm like
this is great yeah chud on chud versus
chud it's like this is great like MAA
versus Maga and Nazi vers Nazi like this
is [__] fantastic I cannot tell you
how happy this makes me and the media is
all distracted by all kinds of shiny
objects when they can narrow in on this
and be like this is Trump's people like
these are the people who are the most
loyal to trumpism like they are the most
loyal to these brain dead qinon type
ideas that's who these people are um so
but I I I'm glad that you know who these
people are so you can identify them for
us so well go go ahead so so I the woman
like I said her name is Lori I actually
know her very very well and it's a
complex story but after the first Convoy
imploded right and I started showing up
as the lone counter protester to the
group the people who had originally been
part of that first Convoy and were mad
because it ended up like the leaders
stole money and left all the
participants of the Convoy in a parking
lot and most of those people were living
out of their cars and had giv up their
jobs for that Convoy and everything so
it was this big drama thing so I show up
you know the small bit of the Convoy
that's left counter protesting and the
people who had left the group but were
once part of it and were Maga or
whatever conservatives um liked that and
they started also showing up in counter
protesting so there were a few chuds and
non chuds that joined and Lori was one
of them so she was part of the Convoy
and then she came to protest and so um
she was in DC for a while protesting uh
the J Sixers
but uh without saying too much she she
supported January 6 but she didn't
support the grifters right the live
streamers in the grifters making money
off of it um and so she had her moment
here in DC where she was helping me and
others counter protest um and then she
went on back her way to where she's from
and is with the proud boy um and you
know is still to my knowledge a trump
supporter and she even during her
altercation with this pedophile here
says that the cause is righteous and she
supports it so she does
you know she's there counter protot the
grifting streamers and pedophiles but
the whole border whatever idea they have
um she supports it makes it really
complicated doesn't it like it really
complicates things I want to show you
another video and I don't I don't know
if you know this lady but this one is
going Super Gang Busters is that mon all
all all over all over on Twitter oh
that's her that's who I'm talking about
that's him in the car the pedophiles in
the car car okay so so this is the same
car just from a different angle and this
is and this is who her name is Lori this
is Lori the chud right this is Lori the
chud um am I am I allowed to call her
that or should I I mean yeah it's it's
one of those things that's complicated
because she's not you know like she was
and then she wasn't and then she still
holds on to some ideas so it's it's a
complex it's a
it's
she's she's half chud dating a full
proud boy is that the uh I don't want to
like so when this H you if you're
following me on Twitter I'm posting like
all of you know the highlights of what's
going on and that happened I was
watching it live I was watching Lori
stream and I was watching the pedophile
stream it was like a battle of the live
streamers right and so I didn't want to
put that on Twitter because I know Lori
and I knew it looked crazy but it got
out there anyway and then it just really
got out there so I don't want to come on
here like I'm not you know like the
other guys I'll talk full [__] about
like they're horrible garbage well in
this video with Lori you're gonna see
her actually speak against the grifters
like you said so she's gonna speak
against them and it's kind of going um
viral because she's doing that um and it
just because it feels like when people
listen to this U this little diet tribe
that she has against the grifters it's
like well I mean isn't that the whole
point of Maga and Trump like Ain that
the whole thing with January 6 and
grifting yeah um but I have some
comments here Keith says so she's semi
fascist I don't know if that's um if
that's for like the the the the semi
trucks um punch a punch a Nazi Convoy um
crystal says crystal says on Facebook
says I love how apete knows about this
um and that's really why the same people
right like all all of these no matter
what right-wing EV it is there's always
live streamers okay and and they just go
from one event to the next and and so so
so let wait a second let's let's talk
about that for a second and you're
saying it's the exact same live
streamers and you're saying that the
live streamers are the actual grifters
or the grifters are taking advantage of
the live
streamers so the grifters are the live
streamers like I don't necessarily okay
people will say grifting when you're
live streaming um what these not Lori
Lori is not the one doing this but there
there's some other streamers that are
there that were at j6 you know or with
the other Convoy like what whatever
Crazy rightwing Event they've been there
but anywh who what they'll what they'll
do is just you know spread
misinformation lie you know take little
clips and likes and shares um and then
people believe all that nonsense and
they send them all these all this money
like these little old ladies in their
streams if you look at their algorithm
or whatever ever their analytics like
everyone is over 60 and female for the
most part a large chunk of Their
audience and they'll literally send them
their social security and their
disability so all these nonsense videos
that we know is not the real story right
like the the
more false rhetoric that they put out
there um the more these Granny's just
eat it up and just s send the money so
like most of those streamers that are
there literally live off of the money
like if pays their mortgage it pays for
their two cars their pool you know for
them to travel two of those guys have
been on the road doing this for several
weeks now so they've rented cars and
hotels every single day and drove up and
down the country um and mean just to
continue this grift yeah yeah yeah so
well in that video in the video with the
proud boy and Lori um the
the half manga um they they they
mentioned and deer has it up here she
they mentioned someone called Master
grifter who's Master grifter who is this
oh my God okay because because they're
they're actually call not only not only
are they grifting but they're calling
themselves grifter right I mean they're
yeah so it was there's a group of they
call trolls you know like the community
that I associate with that works hard to
you know take this stuff down so he had
that group had been calling him like
Master group
few times and he he picked it up do you
really want to know about this
individual because it's just it's really
terrible well I mean so is is he in is
he is he a part of this Convoy or yes so
he the original Convoy and she not
original but the one in 2022 he was part
of that and that had different
organizers like here here's the issue so
the people's Convoy of 2022 had um
truckers that were the organizers there
was like four of them and all the
participants in the group were just
random you know people or whatever so
this new organization this new Convoy
has completely different organizers with
a completely different agenda however
all the participants are of the original
Convoy so they're like we're not
following these rules like we're gonna
this isn't how you do things this is
what we're going to want to do um what
what was what was I saying I forgot
about the master grifter about master
grifter oh yeah yeah so he was in the in
in this first cont and so now he's
attached himself to the second Convoy
and the organizers are not truckers like
the first one so it's it's poorly done
like they can't get through
intersections you know they didn't get
approval to use the parking lots that
they were asking so they're getting
kicked out of places like they're almost
causing accidents it's it's really
disorganized
so well I was gonna say I've got a live
shot now this is from an account called
real conal rump it it feels like it
feels like there's some of the best
footage from the live stream coming from
this account con rump um so if you want
to see a lot of the footage and the
timeline of some of this footage you're
going to want to go to Twitter and just
follow at real conell rump um and all
the videos yes no so this this is um
this is five minutes ago and this is a
video of uh it says Simon is repeatedly
hanging out the window with a megaphone
beef says it's okay because he's in he's
in really good shape a local driver fed
up with their [__] tries to get through
and beef that dangerous so let's play
just a little bit of this and we'll come
back to the of the video of Lor
grifter so you can see him this is the
trucker Convoy where there's no trucks
these are
[Laughter]
cars and of course you know oh my God
this is so safe guys this is totally
normal he's got a freaking megaphone and
a flag
oute and of
course so do you do you know do you know
I'm GNA I'm going to mute this do you
guys do you know this this guy hanging
out the window called beef apparently
well beef is the one that's in the car
this is her POV and she's oh okay okay
okay Simon is the one hang yeah Simon's
the one hanging out of the car sorry
yeah Simon was with you know the other
Convoy which became the 1776 restoration
movement and he actually he got like
escorted out of an event in DC one time
because he showed up I think it was the
women's March wearing a n a um what do
you call it what's the Nazi symbol thing
their
littlea yeah he wore he had a swastika
t-shirt um and it was something about
vaccines and mandates so it had like
needles on the end of the swastika but
he showed up to I believe it was the
women's March wearing that and of course
everybody you know was made a scene and
was saying things to him and the cops
had to like remove him for his own
safety but he apparently is like an
airline like a flight attendant I guess
or something this guy this guy is yeah
this Nazi flies around the country on
airplanes and is responsible for
people's safety on airplanes are you
serious yes oh my God if if a woman is
flying the it's all female right exactly
this white guy is right but but Nazis
Nazis cool women we got a question right
is that the okay all right well you know
it is 2024 and [__] but you know who am
I trying to say um but obviously um this
Trucker's Convoy is not doesn't have
very many truckers in it that's the one
thing I want to ask you one truck one
truck two now maybe two oh oh is it a
two truck Convoy oh it's a pair it's a
pair now it's a pair of
trucks a couple a couple of trucks um so
that was that was from not too long ago
just like 15 minutes ago um now I want
to go back to this video of Lori so that
we can kind of commentate this because
this one's kind of getting a lot of
attention because she's speaking out
against again uh some people some one
person asked if this is U let me see if
I can find it Tony Phillips ask is this
Mike Lindell because this guy in the car
this this this chomo in the car he kind
of looks like Mike Lindell a little bit
I'm not I'm not gonna lie I'm not gonna
lie I don't know if he's Mike lindell's
doppelganger and I don't know if you've
ever seen Mike Lindell and this guy at
the very same place at the very same
time so you never know I mean it might
be you know how you what do you you
never know you never know could be AI
That's right is it real or is it AI now
I actually when I first saw this clip or
um this thumbnail this video how this is
positioned I actually thought that she
was she was doing a video against a
green screen um how this is positioned
but it looks like she might be sitting
down or crouched on the ground or
something to get this pedophile's car in
the background but this is Lori this is
the the the proud boy proud boy um half
Maga girlfriend here let's listen to
let's listen to let's listen to her
commentary on grifters to the
Christians do not be deceived stop
thinking that everybody who waves a flag
and shouts freedom is your friend and a
good person because we have people like
this trying to join up in the movements
I found this out the hard
way I found it out the hard way now do
you do you know the story here because
it feels like it's a very personal story
to her and it feels like um that she's
been public about it may maybe she
hasn't but um she she's obviously um
been slighted in some way against or
these grifters have grifted her in some
way and I imagine it's if it is money
it's probably a some substantial amount
of money um but it feels like it's also
time in this movement you know she's
she's been a chud before maybe not a
chud uh at one point again a chud not a
chud you know I I guess maybe that's how
it works uh in chud in chud land
sometimes but it feels like she's had
some insight some Enlightenment that
these people are taking advantage of her
and her fear right I mean to some degree
yeah so I just sent you I just sent you
two pictures it's literally the
pedophiles POV versus Lor's po so while
this is going on he's sitting live
streaming her and she's kind of crouched
down on the parking lot but yes this
this is very personal um Let me let me
let me pull those go ahead keep going
yeah this is very personal for Lori like
I said she was part of the other Convoy
and you know she got scammed like it the
people's Convoy was important to her you
know she Freedom the co all whatever her
reason was that was important to her and
she invested all of her time I mean this
went on for months like it wasn't a
couple days like these people lived in
their cars and lived in parking lots and
gave up everything to follow the
original Convoy only for the organizers
to not actually accomplish anything they
literally accomplish nothing and then
run off with millions of dollars they
they were they they raised millions and
millions of dollars from just random
people off probably social SEC kind of
like Lori here now this is her
perspective this is her perspective and
this is the perspective that you sent me
um where she is crouched down see that
yeah so I was I was right because it
looked it looked kind of in this image
or at this Viewpoint it did look like um
that she was crouched down and then this
one here uh obviously shows that she is
crouched and sitting so yeah um let's
let's continue and let's hear a little
more of what Lori has to say about the
grifters so everybody is in things for
the same reasons you
are I was in the people's Convoy and
what a [__] disappointment that ended
up
being what a disappointment
to find out that these people that you
were with they weren't like you they
didn't care about the
country they were a bunch of grifting
[__] live streamers that wanted
to make
money off of the people in America who
were hardworking and sending their money
little old
ladies old men people who had to wait
for their paychecks so they could give a
little bit of money to help people drive
around and Shout freedom and fight for
freedom I want to ask you because you
know Lori personally it sounds like um
do you think she feels the same way
about people like Roger Stone or Alex
Jones or um maybe maybe some of the
other proud boys or oathkeepers or or
Donald Trump himself do you CH or a
Carrie Lake some of these big
fundraisers like margorie Taylor green
margorie Taylor's green is doing a
magnificent job by the way really really
stoking fear in this country um she's a
big fundraiser she likes to spread these
lies and misinformation about the border
right now there's not as many people
coming across the border that's why we
don't have images of these people down
at the Border in in in in Eagle Pass
because there's not that many people
walking through Eagle Pass right now
there's there just not and and it's one
reason why is because it's a certain
time of year these things come in waves
I mean just as many people crossed the
border When Donald Trump was President
as Joe Biden it's just that's just the
facts that you you can't get away from
that and really the people coming across
the imaginary line isn't the problem
it's how we're treating them when we get
here which is a problem I think but do
you think do you think that Lori has
because you know her personally is there
is there a certain sort of cognitive
distence that she's operating under
where she ignores one grift but she's
focused in on another and is that is
that that complicated issue that you're
talking about and how it's um it's hard
to undo some of these things and
unraveled the delusion sometimes do you
think that's part of it or what what
what's your view on that yeah so well
like I said I was out you know
protesting the group by myself and Lori
and a few others showed up and I was
very apprehensive to you know about her
and about some of the others because
these people were Maga they were part of
this movement um and so there were
things we agreed about and things we did
not agree about at all um
and like I said Lori was around in the
area for a while um she she has a rabbit
um that she was bringing with her a pet
rabbit pet rabbit so um the rabbit
actually stayed with me for a while okay
so so you baby said you baby oh okay all
right yeah so I mean she was living out
of her car and she every single day was
going into the same you know protest
that I was and she she was she was not
like them and and she was changing her
ways you know she wasn't there was
there's a lot of great things about Lori
like I don't I don't want to bash Lori
um you know and so she grew and she
blossomed and and she stop you know got
away from the Kool-Aid right like right
she she realized that all of that [__]
was an issue and she was coming down
from that and doing great um
and those those people from those other
groups caused a lot of issues for her
she was live streaming you know when
you're out on the internet you know oh I
know oh I know I know so all of that you
know the worst things that can happen
when you're on the internet happened to
her and so she she um took a step back
you know when she had been here in DC in
the area you know she had um gone to
some like you know women's and lgbtq
events and you know she she was changing
her mind about things so and that's
really the thing for me like I know a
lot of the internet just sees me you
know yelling and being vile or whatever
but it's really
um we can't fight these people forever
like that right like literally there
would be a civil war because they're not
they're not there's some people you can
talk to and some that you can't some are
no matter what not going to change their
mind right but there are others right
and Lori and a few others like that I've
I've befriended along the way and and so
that caused actually caused a lot of
drama for me people are like wow would
you associate with that person and I was
like well you know you got the chance to
save her right yeah yeah yeah I mean not
I don't I'm not like saving her I'm not
like you know you're not Jesus You're
Not Jesus
yeah she did that all on her own it was
just you know the influence of who she
was around and you know there was other
people Ian you know you know there
there's there's a lot to be said when
you when you extend your truth and you
extend your heart to someone maybe
they'll just think you know maybe I
should think a little more about what
I'm doing and man it sounds like what
she did and and again I think I think
this is uh the perfect way to talk about
Lori here to someone who actually knows
her right because I'm I'm gonna be
honest with you I would totally just run
her through the ringer here and totally
Mock and give all kinds of [__] here
so I appreciate that you've come on and
you have actually said look this lady
has some problems and a lot of those
problems stem from maybe a lot of the
ideas that she has that are based on not
so much the truth and and that she she
may she may or she may not come out of
that that delusion of some of this
misinformation she obviously have come
out of some of it because she wouldn't
be sitting here making this video
talking these grifters in the background
these pedophile grifters in the
background if she hadn't come to some
kind of truth I mean she's she knows
what the truth is to some degree
I I mean in some areas so maybe maybe
just maybe Lori will come out of this um
so I I do want to go back to the uh
conell
rump and see because I want to show some
of these videos uh from last night um
from the the I don't know what the hell
they were doing it was it some sort of
concert or something or oh my God Sarah
pal Palin was there Ted nent was there
um like all of the worst people showed
up there were January Sixers so yeah
they the organizers like raised like at
least a hundred grand but didn't pay for
anybody's gas or you know lodging or
anything so this whole time we've been
like what is all this money for was it
you know there was no trucks was it this
one wrapped bus well they show up in
Dripping spring last night Dripping
Springs whatever and freaking Ted nent
comes in a helicopter s Sarah Palin's
there all these local politicians oh my
God wait a second wait a second wait
wait AP AP wait a second so their
headliner was Ted nent last night and
apparently um it was supposed to be it
was three hours into the Ted nent show
and Ted nent was actually on stage for
like 13 minutes I'm G I'm gonna play a
clip here yeah um but the trucker's
Convoy and and Ted
nent in total boneheaded fashion decides
that he's gonna show up in a helicopter
and not a [__] semi TR I mean the guy
can afford no I'm dead serious
yeah I'm dead listen if if I'm if I'm
gonna put on a show right and I'm gonna
I'm gonna create some political theater
around a trucker's Convoy I'm not I mean
I might fly down somewhere else get out
of the helicopter and and you know
Common deer a semitruck or have a truck
driver who is lik to the cause I mean
I'm sure Ted nja can find one [__]
truck driver within 60 miles of this
children's Christian Camp that these
people went to CU they didn't go to the
Border they went to a children's camp um
yeah but I'm sure that he could he could
find one trucker that was willing to get
in his semi- truck and and Truck Ted
nett so they had the camera with truck
net popping out of a truck and it was
the trucker Convoy I mean come on I'm
with all the lights and he's supposed to
be like a he's supposed to be like a
superstar to put on a show right he
couldn't even figure that out come on
man that's ridiculous well here's the
clip uh apparently of Ted n maybe
finally arriving or something I
let's see what the um what they're going
to say here oh this is this weird
guy
question you gotta talk into the
microphone yeah you gota you gotta talk
into the
microphone he's still not talking into
look at this guy can't what is he doing
what is he doing does he know how a
microphone works what are who are these
people by the time they got to this guy
I have no idea what was going on I don't
know what he was talking about he said
something about a seven the the left has
a 700 year plan and then he kind of goes
oh yeah the seven no no no he's right Us
in antifa us see I broadcast from the
antifa corporate
headquarters here in Tomy Falls Missouri
and we definitely we have a big we have
a big eache whiteboard and it's got our
700 year plan on it it's got it all I
mean all that Adrina clone or whatever
it is you know we we have all of that so
oh no no we don't we don't have water
coolers we don't have water coolers here
at the antifa corporate headquarters we
have a Drea Chrome coolers you you can
get it fresh that's secret yeah sh yeah
you know don't tell I don't tell anybody
that but let's listen to the guy who's
not talking into the microphone let's
see if we can hear what he says Jesus
Christ these
people
urg yeah put it to your mouth hold it
hold it up to your mouth how a
microphone yeah we can't hear
you face oh okay oh okay yeah you gotta
talk into it
dummy yeah yeah all right the left has a
several hundredy year plan since Russo
wrote yeah the essay on inequality yeah
we sure do the professors the priests
the
press the prosecutors the politicians
uhuh and the parents it's a ppppppp plan
AP it's a
ppppppp yeah we're going to get rid
pastors the prosecutors the pastors the
the the the politicians the the pastors
um the the Pol did I say the politicians
uh it's a p p and the pedophiles too
yeah yeah right right it's a we got the
peeee tapes too somewhere uh here at the
antifa corporate headquarters let's
let's listen to what else he has to say
about before Ted nent takes the stage
they have to take them all over in order
they have five of the seven PS right now
they need to take they need to turn a
few more red States blue oh my God in
order to finally achieve it so they
can oh my God nominate okay AP it really
feels like he read this on Facebook
somewhere and he's just trying to repeat
what he read on Facebook Am I Wrong yes
and and his mom told him that
he what the [__] is this the kind of
stuff that you hear when you're out and
about in Washington and they're kind of
like coun protesting you or something is
it do they say this they kind of protest
me and it's not so much that they're out
in the open they kind of stay to one
spot and hide away from the public so
that they have no you know opposition to
their to what they're saying um but yeah
they usually just say completely
like all all this Sovereign citizen
stuff and everyone is like George Soros
and everyone is a fed and demons I'm a
demon and you know there's like tracking
devices and and the 5G is making us
zombies like at this point absolutely
nothing surprises me the only thing that
surprised me was that Ted nent actually
showed up well you know you know
speaking of demons here at the antifa
corporate headquarters when when we
actually give out your official gold
membership card we need a blood test um
number one we want to make sure you've
been drinking the blood of of children
as the blood sucking Ball but we also we
also want to make sure that you're a
verified demon right we send it in we it
to what's the 23 and pure blood demon
yeah we send it to 23 and me and they
verify that you're a pure blood demon
that way we know here at the antifa
corporate headquarters that we can give
you the gold membership card not just
the membership card because there's a
difference right you're you're verifi
you get a blue check you get a blue
check on on your yeah just like you get
a blue check on uh on Twitter I don't
know do you know this oh she popped out
she must have lost over here there she
is um do you know this guy right here
yeah that's I know him very well that's
Ivan riklin and he's the one that I am
um accusing of being the pipe bomber on
January 5th oh
really they called him Ivan the pipe
bomber here are maybe he's the he maybe
maybe he's the bite pommer I don't know
the bite pommer is Ivan the bite pommer
um here and he was down there is this
his walker or is this someone else's oh
my God so so
he this guy is crazy okay he's heavily
associated with Flynn like he is Flynn's
like wait wait wait you mean you mean
you mean General Mike Flynn oh okay this
is the Pence card guy or whatever you
know the we could go on and on for it
but anyway so this little man Ivan racen
um broke his leg he called it a tobogan
he was sledding a week or two ago and
his story is that he was sedding and his
foot ended up under the tobogan you know
between the tagen and the snow that's
how he said it so he broke his leg and
he had to be like evacuated from the
snow I guess like an emergency crew had
to pull him out of the snow or something
so again he's very crazy so he's been
making videos even while he was like
pretty much sedated under pain pillars
saying like you know 50% pain whatever
that stupid quote is 10% gain I don't
know um preparing for this boy like
because if anyone is pushing any violent
rhetoric it is this [__] right
here so he accidentally breaks his leg
before this Convoy but he's bound and
determined to go so he's been like you
know like tough guying himself like like
like you know getting through the pain
like meanwhile I shouldn't be walking on
this broken leg but like a day after
he's out does he does he know that they
have um wheelchairs does he know that
they exist he was in a wheelchair this
started in Virginia um like last week
and he showed up in Virginia in his
wheelchair you know he loves he loves
the media he loves cameras he loves to
talk did his little thing in his
wheelchair and then chased people around
in Congress Ashley bab's mom's been
Wheeling him around in his wheelchair in
the halls of Congress all week it's
almost it's almost like Ashley babbit's
Mom has something to do with this little
man as you called him here and then this
little man has something to do with Mike
Flynn that seems I don't know it just it
seems kind of like a coincidence to Me
Maybe right right kind of funny now I
want to show you I want to set the scene
here for the audience because you got
the little man here with the Walker who
hurt his he hurt his leg snow sleding
apparently um and then and then in the
background here you see all these um
Caucasian type folks standing in front
of a cross I just want to know did they
schedule a cross burning at this thing
what what in the [__] what are you
serious they have a cross and they're
gonna are they gonna burn this thing or
something what the hell going on they
eventually shut the cameras off so they
probably burned it
after is that is that when they put
their robes and their hoods on to yeah
start calling it The Clan boy after this
rally the clan boy hey I like that I
like that the clan boy what Ivan is
about to say is like a sprinkle on the
vanilla ice cream tone of what what go
on oh there was plenty of anti-Semitism
there was plenty of anti I'll show you
that clip too but here's here's Ivan the
bite pommer um with his little broken W
from snow sweating right before they
burn the cross let's listen and what is
a Marauder a Marauder is a pirate that
goes on to a ship the Deep State
Marauder
treasure
booty so what does that mean that means
you need to confront these scum in
person that means Elon musos needs to go
ahead and go into all of their direct
messages and release them to the public
to Showcase number want those
[Music]
thatn my buddy General listen here's the
thing here's the thing here's the thing
he said confront he this is he literally
said we need to confront these people in
person and then he continued to say that
we're not actually going to confront
them in person what we're going to do is
go get their digital footprint and then
we're going to release their digital
footprint on the internet not actually
confronting them in person what a
[__] [__] what a [__] [__] he
wants Twitter to release the private
messages of people but when they were
when they did or tried to do that to
Trump yeah no absolutely not AP that
would that would make him not a
hypocrite you can't have that Ivan the
bite pomber here Ivan the bik bomber is
definitely a hypocrite I'm sure I'm sure
of it I'm almost positive I love how
he's I love how he cries though they
whine and cry about Mike Flynn that is
[__] haayer poor Mike Flynn oh poor M
poor traitor poor traitor I make this
joke a lot it's one of the best Tweets
I've ever had and I retweet it all the
time um and it goes like this I took a
huge [__] this morning and it smelled
like a traitor so much I had to name it
Mike Flynn that's that's what I that's
what I named it it was so disgusting it
smelled so much like a traitor this guy
this guy's not far behind him here this
Ian the the the the bite pommer um let
me show you the anti-semitic uh little
rant that happened oh wait wait wait no
here here is um here's the entrance of
um Ted nent I believe yeah yeah let's
play this let's let's play um him
walking around the where he's walking
and here he is and he's holding story
here he is here he is should I play the
audio on this yes definitely okay let's
play the audio let's play
the
God bless
you I am I am the Border I'm with you m
thank you and yes you are always God
bless you
hun I like it a that good I just got it
today God bless you we're gonna do it
thank you Pat I'm Glory Be freedom God
bless you
deare we're not we're just standing this
is our
normal
anytime you're ready that looks nice
though it
does that's his
truck this is the truck for the trucker
Convoy there's there's his helicopter in
the background there you can see he
didn't actually come now so he did get
in a truck but he didn't actually get in
the semi truck he's already there like
helipad is at the rally these people are
so
stupid
nuh that's filming that I called beef
earlier Glory bee freedom but oh this is
beef okay yeah yeah she she had She's
Always a mess like she's always lost and
late and everything so the the whole
rest of the rally is somewhere else and
she was having like phone issues
charging issues or something so she just
happen to be at her car as this like
helicopter lands and then she goes over
there with our camera like like he's
such an like a big celebrity and so
amazing oh he is he is you you heard
that the left has our s our scop pop
star yeah it's a SC up we we invented
her we invented her he a well well I
don't know I don't know if they're very
good at scops the left is only the ones
that are good at SC antia invented scops
if you want to yeah yeah right speaking
speaking of people who are invented this
is Sarah Palin what in the [__] is she
wearing what don't know what in the [__]
is this so Sarah Palin and if anyone
doesn't know who she is because she's
totally irrelevant at this point that's
why she's there with Ted Nan because
she's totally irrelevant um she actually
she actually ran as the vice president
at one point in 2008 God that scene's
like so long ago um it is it's such
ancient history in politics um but this
is why she didn't win um because of this
this is why she and McCain lost is
because she has to show up to places
like this but let's listen to um Sarah
Palin and puke up into the microphone
let's listen that now more than ever
it's required of us to stand up and
fight for what's right amen because it's
unconscionable it's treat
federal government is do what what is
treasonous what is she what are these
people talking about what is Tre what I
mean you have to be near these CHS all
the time what do they say is treasonous
about the Border What What In the God's
name do they think is treasonous about
the Border um brown people oh they're
racist oh okay that well yeah now that
you say that now that you say that that
that makes sense that makes sense I mean
there's no logical reason they have to
have a problem with the government no
matter what it has to be some tyranny
and some treason there's there's an
agenda for them right um I want to play
oh here's the lady on the scooter again
oh my God this is Mona yeah here do you
know Mona Hill do know met Mona in
person but I'm very familiar with Mona
all these people that live stream also
like will watch my live streams and then
they do they do this streamyard they
call panel and hours a day talking about
me or whoever else yes you should be so
you should oh you should be so proud
that they talk about hopefully they'll
start talking about me then in these
panels that sure they are by now great a
trucker that showed up I guess he goes
by bonehead trucker he wasn't affiliated
with this Convoy but he's he's a
YouTuber has like 250,000 views he
showed up but because he's not like them
they thought he was antifa and they all
this whole big thing like what does that
mean he's not like them was he black he
wasn't white oh okay well I didn't know
I just he's not into like this I don't
know
grifting money show I see I see did you
notice that we got uh your your yeah
yeah we got we got you as sound effects
now on here har done for congress Harry
done for congress Harry done for
Congress are we done we we got we got
your your your [__] as sound effects
now here on the Tony Michaels podcast
made it now yeah that's right I mean we
gotta have Cowboy cowbells whistles and
AP um here is here is um Mona the the
scooter lady she's apparently from my
state she's apparently from Branson
Missouri Branson yeah Branson Branson oh
man I have met a lot of Monas in Branson
Missouri believe it or not let's
listened okay that's speed liit oh
actually got a dog on the back oh yeah
oh yeah it's a freedom
dog that dog's been in every
convy every Convoy huh buddy is that is
that animal abuse I don't know I think
um that might be probably she Liv in
little tiny like RV type thing and she
smokes heavily in there with that dog so
that dog probably has asthma poor dog po
she has to be with Mona and her
cigarette cigarettes and her cigarettes
um there's another video um of Mona and
I played it yesterday but she actually I
don't know if she um sang the song it
kind of pissed me off when I he when I
yeah it kind of pisses me off I'm not
gonna lie because Johnny Cash would not
be down with these people um and the
reason why Johnny Cash wouldn't be down
with these people is because Johnny Cash
isn't a [__] bigot he wasn't a bigot
um he just wasn't that's not who Johnny
Cash was that's not who his his values
were it's not what his principles were
um he was for the Common working man no
matter what their skin color no matter
what their their arrest record whether
they were in prison out of prison uh
Johnny Cash was actually what do they
call it a Christian he was actually
those he was actually one of those I'm
not one I'm an atheist but um I I know
that Johnny KES uh held those beliefs
close to him his entire career because
he he struggled with addiction he
struggled with drugs he struggled with
depression um and and mental illness and
and he he understood because he lost his
brother and I mean there's a there's a
lot of tragedy in Johnny's his life and
and for this lady to do this it kind of
pissed me off at one point but then I'm
like these people really they
appropriate things that they truly don't
understand because if you go listen to
the song that Johnny Cash recorded the
Ragged o flag and I actually don't agree
with Johnny on this issue because Johnny
did a lot of interviews when he released
this song and he talked about how he
thought there should be laws that people
shouldn't burn the flag and I I I don't
agree with that I think Johnny Cash was
wrong on that point I think we
absolutely should have the right to burn
the flag and I think we should have the
right to do it in public and and people
people should be able to be offended by
that or not offended by that that is a
liberty that we should hold there's
people who fought and died under that
flag to make sure that we could burn it
and have the Liberty to burn it I mean
that's important and you know what you
know what [__] really pisses me off
about this more than anything this
lady's gonna sing this ragged old flag
and talk about the flag and and what it
represents and this [__] weirdo is
wearing a wearing a coat made out of a
flag a hat made out of of a flag she's
got flags on her hat which is totally
100% if you're for flag code that is
against flation that's a violation of
flag code so if it means so much to you
if the flag means so much and all this
nonsense and all this [__] and this
Freedom [__] that they always spew then
this lady would not be wearing this get
up singing this or saying this song but
we we'll take a look at it for a minute
an old man was sitting there and I
walked said
hey your Old Courthouse is mighty run
down and he said well yeah but it'll do
for our little town now if you haven't
heard ragano flag it is a song that
Johnny Cash um wrote and he and he he s
well he doesn't really sing much in it
he talks um but it's about a little
little boy that comes up to a man in a
town and says hey your flag on your
courthouse is ragged it's kind of ripped
and torn and tattered and then the old
man sits and he talks about all the
things that tattered the flag and why
it's tattered and one of those things
that really gets me in the song and it
really pisses me off when people like
this uh try to appropriate this song for
the movement they talk about the
Confederacy and they talk about how the
Confederacy tried to take down our flag
and it's not the Confederate flag it's
the [__] American flag and it just
really it gets it gets me really pissed
off and fired up uh when people
appropriate that part of the song um
because I know that Johnny wouldn't be
part of this movement these people would
be his people these people would listen
to his music and they'd love Johnny Cash
but Johnny Cash would show him love back
but he'd show him love back not because
he that he thought the way that they
thought and he would show him love back
the reason why you show Lori love right
is because that there's something that
there's something a human that there's
still a Humanity out there and that's
who Johnny Cash was but this person here
wearing the American flag as a coat and
hat on the hat breaking the flag Cod
over and over and over again just on her
outfit and then and then dictating ragdo
flag is um people who are not Patriots
and cheer her they're nationalists these
people are nationalists there is a
difference between Patriots and
nationalists so I just want to point
that out um I want to show you one more
video on this anti-semitic do you got a
few minutes or you gotta yeah I got got
all right because I gotta I gotta do a I
I also gotta do a workshop um today
we're trying to we're going to try to
teach people how to make Donald Trump
memes for free um yeah well yeah we we
want to we want to cause as much [__]
as we possibly can AP so we're going to
do a little workshop if you want to join
us for the workshop you can uh you can
hang out for the workshop too um as
we're doing this now I want to show you
a video here and I forget the guy's name
he's kind of a fat slob which shouldn't
be a surprise to most people um who are
who are watching some of this um clown
boy that you just call it clan Clan
clany Clan boy the clan boy Clan boy
yeah so so this guy's name is um Michael
Young I think this guy's name is I
believe so I'm not really sure um he's
the one that was talking about the
yeah he was up there talking about
Jewish people now he really got pissed
off he started tweeting and did you know
that he he got really mad that people
clipped him saying anti-semitic stuff
well he got really so there's there's a
local um there's someone who used to do
undercover with like Nazis and yeah
Amanda right here yeah and so she's
there and he's going back and forth with
her this is um this is the one that um
yeah manga infiltrator is what she
claims to be right right she used to
follow me but I'm sure I pissed her off
somehow I probably said something to
make her manad um here I do that a lot
same I don't think she might not even
like me but well I did yeah you know
whatever sh a lot of people don't like
me it's okay by me you know it's it's
fine it's all right if it's okay people
hate you it's all right you know it's
for a good it's for a good cause anyway
to be enemies just because exactly
exactly um so Michael here responds to
Amanda um the maanga infiltrator posting
this video of him he says this account
published this carefully edit video clip
tonight carefully edited okay apparently
trying to play the anti- card for money
um it was you that was saying stuff
about Jewish people there Michael yeah
demanded this dishonest account
published this entire clip okay so she's
like yeah [__] around and find out dude
she
says she says bit she says [__] please
[__] please I only did that for
retention not to make look too what is
here let me uh let me February 3 like 3
th what instead of February third it
says thirst it does here hang on let
me you see right here right above this
this U this Nazi's head this naz's head
it says 3
th they didn't use the spell check on
the banner before they printed it what
the [__] did they stood in front of
that and Ted nent Ted nent showed up
three hours late to stand in front of
this Banner apparently oh my God I think
that Ted nent was actually on time and
the the context of that one tweet was
like Ted nent showed up and all this was
like supposed to be for him and he
literally was there for 13 oh so it's
supposed to be a huge like a concert and
he didn't do a concert yeah and then for
three hours just random people talked
and by the end that weird guy gets on
and says it's 700 you know what I'm I'm
sure and you know what this this all is
making sense with this Banner now AP now
that I'm thinking about this I think I
think they actually mistaken um the
dates this is a misprint and it's
supposed to be 30th of February the 30th
of February not yeah the 30th of
February which we all know is just as
much of a day as The Thirst of so the
combo will be bigger the rest will show
up right exactly they'll show up on them
February 30th they'll they'll be there
to show up and say Nazi ass [__] like
this let me play this here is filled
with Colton seen them Taylor seen them
and vandersteel seen them and they're
coming across our border every day right
let me tell you what Hamas are you
listening to me listen Hamas is coming
across hesa is coming across Venezuela
is filled with hesah you understand that
venezuel okay so I want to pause it here
because obviously he knows how to use
the microphone better than the other guy
um clearly he's a much better mic user
than the first guy we listened to but
okay so so he's not only is he stoking
like brown people Mexican fear right
he's like oh and the Muslims too the
Muslims too it's not just the brown
Mexican be it's the other brown ones too
like he's like he's really leaning into
that what I don't really understand
about the next part is that well let me
just play ITA is filled with hesah they
speak Spanish fluently their soccer team
is Venezuelan right their body language
is Venezuelan they grew up in Venezuela
they're coming across constantly one of
the main groups that brings Brett
Weinstein just you see that message he
just sent anyway one of the main funders
of this well the United States is the
main fun right another main fun is
actually is highest highest the Hebrew
Aid Society Jewish right this is Jewish
he yes Jewish as if the as if all the
[__] Nazis in the crowd are like yeah
we know what Hebrew means
man they even know what he's talking
about it all oh my God this guy this
guy's crazy um let's keep going with the
with with the the worst of the worst
here what what have you ever met was
this guy part of the other Convoy is
this just another type of Griff that's
going on here um I don't think that he
was part of the Convoy Amanda whose
footage that is she has a thread about
him a little bit I briefly went through
it but I'm okay well let's let's see
what else this uh this psychopath Nazi
says quite interesting because they are
actually fun the people they're going to
come to places like Fort Lauderdale
synagogues and they're going to
scream and they're gonna shoot the [__]
out of them right and they're coming
across the border and they're being it's
being funded with Jewish money right and
highest.org has the names of many of the
funders on their website our borders are
wide open it's our government that's
okay if if folks are wondering why this
doesn't make any sense because it
doesn't it does do make any sense to be
mad about right right and and he
probably found this on Facebook and he's
yelling it now into a microphone this is
the Q andon way you know like um if I
sound smart then I must be smart to all
the dumb people like that's exactly I
guess that's where they go with this um
so uh I wanna I want to give Amanda
credit here even though she doesn't
follow him anymore it's okay it's all
right Amanda maybe will after this yeah
maybe she will once I give her credit
that she was on podcast make a make a
Youtube short now um I can't I can't go
switch to the meme part because I want
to do the meme Workshop here with you if
you want to stick around uh you're more
than welcome to but I want to go to this
you posted this morning um because I'm
really looking forward to the next Peter
Navaro getting a cowbell shoved up his
ass here soon so um Scott McFarland
reported this morning in an overnight fi
filing Peter Navaro asked to remain free
pending appeal um so what what what what
do you expect do you expect there to be
a hearing that you may or may not be
able to show up to and I don't know
maybe ring a cowbell and hold a sign or
something I don't know um well we all
knew that Navaro was gonna appeal this
this is what um Steve Bon did yeah Steve
Bon did I I I actually I actually think
they're gonna Grant him this if you if
you I think they're gonna Grant him the
ability to stay out on appeal I think
that's I'm sure that they will I'm sure
that they absolutely will so normally
you know it would be he got sentence and
then they would schedule a day that he
had to turn himself in and that could be
weeks or months or whatever but if
they're going to allow him to stay out
during the appeal process he will go to
the courthouse and appeal it and have an
appeal hearing which is usually pretty
quick I think they I'm not like an
attorney or anything but I think they
get like 10 minutes each or 20 minutes
or something it's pretty quick so um yes
if he goes to that maybe his just
attorneys would go but probably not
because he always needs oh he's
definitely gonna set up a microphone
yeah yeah yeah he's definitely gonna
want a video go viral where you're
standing in the background holding a cow
do you know do you know it's at to some
degree at this point the only relevance
that Peter Navaro has is that a cowbell
is rang in his ear like that's the only
can I tell you how this even started
with Navaro yes let's do that so
irrelevant that standing behind him that
day with that sign was complete accident
I mean not even an accident so much is
he wasn't my target that day Enrique
tario was getting sentenced the you know
the so you were at the courthouse to
watch enrio enrio yeah to watch Enrique
tario and so I had a bunch I had if you
see um on some other angles I have like
a proud Boy sign like prison boy or
something like that and I had that Trump
sign so that Not only was Taro getting
sentenced but some other proud boys had
been getting senten and they had an
Entourage there at the courthouse and
it's it's the same drifting live
streamer people or whatever so they were
having this thing and I was there with
my signs like ruining their day all day
long um and then the judge for tario
like had got sick or something so they
couldn't do his sentencing so now all
these these chuds are just lingering
around like big sad because they came in
from out of town and everything and I've
been bothering them all day so they're
like doing this like prayer circle and I
get forward and I wander away and I'm
like people can do at a prayer circle
you might get get so I'm like
contemplating leaving and I'm packing my
stuff up and the one thing I do at the
courthouse so so when Navaro comes out
to do his little pressers there's quite
a bit of media there right
normally um there's always some media
there but if there's like a ton of
people it's because someone big is there
so I've gotten
really used to just watching the
photographers right like they could sit
there for eight hours so you can get a
sense that something's going to happen
just because they start gaggling they
start putting their stuff together
they're like oh [__] there's something
going on so you're like I got to get
there no it's not even like they're like
oh [__] like I'm sitting I'm sitting
quite a ways from them I'm up like it's
like a big Park and I'm I'm up a little
ways and I look over and I just see
there's a few photographers that I'm
really familiar with that have been
sitting like all day and all of a sudden
they're putting their cameras together
and they're standing up and they're
moving closer to the door so I was like
what's going on what's going on and out
walks [__] Peter Nar like I I
wasn't like really following the court
schedule as much as I am now so like I I
had no idea he was going to be there and
so I'm I was live streaming at the time
and I'm like what the [__] is this what
the [__] is this and they're like oh
it's Navaro blah blah blah and so I'm
like oh and I here's the even funnier
part so all of these chug characters
they have all these weird nicknames
right and mo most of them came up with
the names but some of them we've changed
and so there's this one guy we call
meatwad okay he you know meatwad that
you know that cartoon character um okay
best mewat so he is a meatwad okay so
he's always doing really stupid things
and um he's a January six supporter and
so one day in front of the courthouse he
had like a j6 you know did nothing wrong
or something sign and there's always
media there and he got behind the
broadcaster and held up his sign like
his j6 sign and it it was just like
funny to watch that thing so anyway as
lavaro comes out I had never I've always
had signs but I've never like directly
just gone right into their space you
know where they're doing their pressor
and stood behind them um so I was like
what would mewad do because he
got that's right that's right that's
right right let's go viral baby let's go
viral baby find him and then like it
shouldn't have even been a thing like
novaro made it a thing because he
immediately like I stood there forever
he didn't even notice me and that's why
I had said the whole situational
awareness thing because I had started
off back further and just kept inching
my way closer because he had no idea I
was there for like five minutes with the
sign so by the time I get where I'm
directly behind him he says something um
he's like where's the where's the real
where's the whatever he said something
about where's the media and he says
where's CNN and I was like where's
Michael phenone Michael phenone is the
you know from j6 and we for CNN so I'm
like where is fenon and then um I say
hero because I'm like obsessed with
Michael fenon and that's when thear
notices I'm behind him and he
immediately like grabs my sign and that
whole thing right tries to assault you
yeah yeah so he nobody would have even
noticed until he started like doing all
that dumb [__] and then because the
proud boy thing was going on there's
this they have the proud boys have den
mothers like they're [__] Boy Scouts
okay they have women that like do their
laundry and bring them snacks to the
capital I'm not they got they got
sandwich makers they
got oh my God I'm done I can't I'm done
I'm just I'm kidding I'm kidding I can't
oh my
God they're [__] Boy Scouts yes yes
the [__] Boy Scouts and so the dead
mother gets mad that I'm doing this to
Navaro and she comes over with her flag
and then you know my son is in front of
flag and so it just became this whole oh
you're blocking the flag and you know do
they wear shirts like my my son is a
proud boy and he gets straight A's in
school they were sure he's on the honor
roll my proud boy is on the honor roll
they were no but there was an
insurrectionist who um wore like a
little tiny book bag like a little me
that said my mom thinks I'm special my
mom I'm special identified by I don't
know if it was the Sedition hunters or
the FBI but anyway he was identified by
the some special book bag so I gotta go
back because I knew I could count on my
audience here when you said I was
thinking what would meatwad do so they
put
W WW nwd we need to make the little you
remember the wwjd bracelets you remember
those you need to make WW nwd what would
meatwad
do what I'm making all we're making all
of these people famous today that
beening years absolutely like what what
what would meatwad do in this moment
what kind of stupidity would meatwad
come up with this is hilarious all right
so I wanna I wanna um I want to switch
gears here because I want to show
everyone um this Meme
Maker you like memes on the internet
don't you I sure do yeah every yeah why
not and we're gonna we're gonna how to
make them well hey I'm going to show you
today how to make these here's here's
one here's one I made of trump it says
who loves drugs the fent andol fur
that's who um so you know you know the
story of Ronnie Jackson really giving um
Trump all kinds of drugs in the White
House apparently is just mountains of
drugs like Hunter Biden Hunter B it kill
Hunter Biden and his dick so much drugs
like Hunter Biden wouldn't stand a
chance against this kind of drugs that's
how much drugs for that right right why
are you getting prescribed sentinol like
for what reason I mean the guy likes
drugs I mean I mean you know he he's got
uppers he's got downers he's got
middlers he's got you know he's got all
kinds of stuff going on uh Grandpa
Grandpa shitler does now you know Hitler
Hitler was a drug addict too you know
yeah oh [__] yeah he he he he was in
continent for a while because he was
taking so much [__] well yeah that's
why he does because he takes so much
goddamn Aderall but here's this is
called um M or excuse me imgflip so
image flip.com
imgflip.com you just go to this it's
really simple I'm going to show you a
free way of hack to get around this AP
how you can steal these meat you can
make these memes and steal them don't
tell them I'm doing this mes don't tell
anybody right don't tell anybody's
watching us right no one's watching no
one there's only thousands of people
watching okay so there's a little search
bar let me get rid of the um there we go
okay so I'm gonna get rid of this up
here you see this little little icon
here this little this little thing here
so I'm gonna go here I'm gonna I'm gonna
say Okay I want to find
Trump okay so I just type in Trump there
and I hit search all right oh it's going
to take me to yeah there it goes all
right so then it has pre-built memes or
or pre-built pictures with like where
you can have him um here I'll show you
this one see this one and you can write
right but that but that's a pre-built
one we don't want to do pre-built ones
we want to make our own right um so I
think oh how do we do this again oh [__]
um Imes show more um and there's all
kinds of pre-built ones so there's ones
already built on there that you can do
God damn it where do I go to do this um
create is this that make a meme I think
that's oh [__] okay search all me here
here we go here we go here we go Trump
oh here we go here we go Trump so we
search all right see blank now look at
that look so you can say um uh do I
color right so right okay um
find me
votes um because I'm a loser all right
so see you can you can do all kinds of
cool stuff you just type rules you can
just type in anything you want now
there's there's more and more Taylor
Swift yeah and there's pre-built ones
hey that's a good one um let's let's
see um who's my
fave
scop pop star
I have typer didn't right maybe oh Tai
shop it's not how you spell it quiet
quiet I'm trying to go I'm trying to go
fast here don't matter yeah right well
it's it's Taylor Swift Taylor Swift see
you can do that um my pie shop yeah my
pie shop who's my favorite pie shop piep
um so you can you can play around with
this thing and you can you can get all
kinds of uh crazy good things uh and you
can use new templates you can do all
kinds of stuff you can add images you
can do spacing I know that my friends
are on here right now you can move these
things around um and it's just IMG flip
now here's the here's the um here let me
let me go back to the the one meme that
I had
made here we we'll use the same the one
that I did uh earlier copy and you can
just and you can just have all these
words ready copy paste right maybe who
loves drugs and then uh and then you
copy and then you paste um paste oh look
the uh the fentol furer that's whoo you
see that um so there it is now all you
got to do is you just now it doesn't
show it on my screen here but you you
rightclick on an apple and it says save
image as and you click that and it'll
let you save this image oh yes
theft it's a five finger discount on
memes it's a five finger discount on
memes um otherwise you got to generate
the meme and you got to give them an
email and that sort of thing if you just
right click this thing and save the
image it'll save the image with the
words on it and you just go on about
your way so that is how yeah so you go
to you go to I am gflip that's image
flip
imgflip.com and it's a meme generator
and you can just generate Trump memes
and all kinds of [__] all kind and
you can probably do dark Brandon let's
let's do
dark uh Brandon let's see what let's see
what we got in dark Brandon oh there you
go there you go see it and it just keeps
your same words on here who loves drugs
the fentanyl furer that's who um so you
can you can get all kinds of crazy stuff
going on inside the meme generator so so
everyone should go use the meme
generator if you got a great idea you
should create it with the meme generator
and the thing you should do is go drop
it in the Discord and if you find memes
on the internet that are good go drop
those in the Discord because what we're
going to start doing is we're going to
start taking clips that we have from
YouTube and the shorts and those videos
and we're going to put them in Discord
for you guys to go steal those too you
go download them and then you go you go
post them all over the Internet and give
all kinds of [__] and and that's what
we should be doing just [__]
everywhere just [__] with these
people it's like cowbells on the
internet and comment sections right and
then you post it on Twitter whatever and
say real and then snowlakes will get
really upset with you and demand that
you delete it right exactly and then and
then and then you just tell [__] off
it's your account it's Twitter what do
you want this is xchan really you're
gonna tell me to delete something on
xchan so Mona the one The Beverly
Hillbillies lady wearing flag I'm
getting an update that she has broken
down in the Convoy was in Dripping
spring where they did the little rally
and they were making their way to just
outside of Eagle Pass and um apparently
she's broke down so she's I guess on her
own with oh here here here I got the
video I got the video um hang hang on we
when we report live we report uh live
properly um when we do this so hang on
hang on to your hat here This Is How We
Do It um Connell Connell rump has it
here here's the footage here we go here
we
go uh oh M about Mona
what what about Mona what about her what
about her
is her dog got cancer yet from all the
smoke tighten it up I mean we're uh
we're 200 plus Vehicles La she's brok
down we're going to take up some space
yeah Stitch can you hear
me apparently Mon's broke down somewhere
anybody know
where I mean normally normally a convoy
you're all in line like a convoy is
designed to be a convoy so it's like a
line of vehicles so they don't know
where she's at meaning they're not even
in a line this elderly woman behind
they're not even doing Convoy right
they're not even doing Convoy right the
simple task of Convoy so they're looking
for do they find her in this video let's
see let's see if they found her here
let's get to the end let's see this to
the air conditioner a little bit
um oh my God so pathetic anybody know if
anyone's with Mona anyone's with dog the
cancer dogs with that's said there I
wonder if the dog's name is marbor
that's all I want to know the dog's name
is marbor I think the dog's name that's
what we're going to do Mona and marbor
are lost Mona and maror
if you're interested also I sent you a
link so where the Convoy is that because
they're leaving Dripping Springs and
they're they're not actually going to
Eagle Pass but they are going to that
Children's Ranch which is just outside
of Eagle Pass however it's a large Ranch
like animals and everything and so kind
of their property barrier goes 500 feet
or yards or whatever from the border so
what's this video that you sent here
that is the ranch that they're going to
that's the owner of the ranch and this
is so weird okay let's watch this this
where these people are going no welcome
to Cornerstone Children's Ranch located
in kamato Texas right by the
river um we started here 25 years ago
when we didn't have much here but a
piece of property and that old hay shed
back
there and it's just a plain old cow
pasture since that time we have been
able to have all these buildings put
together and paid for we don't owe
anybody okay so what is it you guys do
out here we meet the needs of about
40,000 people on both sides of the
border which this includes Children's
Home batter women's shelters churches
children's
shelters on both sides of the river
because everybody needs to be loved on
okay well now so those are the people
that use the Ranch battered women
children and then she goes on I don't
know how long this video is I usually
watch these people in I call it super
speed you know yeah yeah well we can we
can do that if you want here let's let's
see she talks about they're just right
near the river you know the border river
whatever and apparently across the
street is where the cartel lives and so
she says some weird things about the
cartel and this is where the Convoy is
headed so this should be we're all about
God's children and I can't think of one
that's not God's child what are you
experiencing out here that uh that is
tied to the Overflow that's coming
across the border what that look like we
spend most of our time with the doors
locked and not going out at night for
fear of company and we have company that
comes through here at different times
when they really shouldn't be and we've
had the cartel even in the warehouse
offering to buy everything we had in the
warehouse and you said cartel wases
right across the street yes right across
street that's right over
here look at that wall across the street
know that's cartel over there by the
operations at strange hours of the night
that you wouldn't operate if you can't
open during the daytime you're probably
doing something you're not close to okay
and so we we're how close to the Rio
Grand right now less than 400 yards less
than 400 yards that's what I've been
told I just live here you guys she just
lives here she doesn't know what
distance is oh my God so they're going
man the clan boy is uh going to the
Children's Ranch with a bunch of
pedophiles in toe this is a really weird
story across the street that's right
this is a really weird story it's very
interesting um I I'm glad that you came
on to talk to me about this today I
really appreciate you coming on again
and um giving us some load down on some
of the people that are in these videos
that way people can I don't know carry
around a little knowledge of who these
people actually are since you've had
firsthand contact with some of them um
and I appreciate it as always you gotta
come back next week um especially if
Peter Nar yes please please keep track
of if there's if if there is just you
know where to get me just say hey there
Peter's gonna be here send me the link
yes I will I will I'm so glad you were
here thanks for joining us thanks for
making means with us too I appreciate it
so much yeah thanks for sh me we'll talk
to you soon everyone go follow satire AP
at satire AP on Twitter follow her
everywhere go to her link tree and
follow her YouTube and all that kind of
stuff off her link tree thank you very
much AP we'll see you soon all right
everybody holy moly what a great show I
know I didn't get to some of the stuff I
wanted to get to some of the the videos
and stuff but man we got to stay on this
clan boy excuse me the pedophile Convoy
whatever you want to call it whatever
want to call it because the media is not
going to talk about this stuff they're
not going to show you what these chuds
are doing um and these are the main
chuds these are the people who are most
dedicated to the manga cause and it's
not that many of them and if this is
really such the crisis that they talk
that it is which it ain't at the
border then maybe there would be more of
them maybe the politicians would be
showing up to this clan boy maybe they
would be involved in this group of the
people going to the Children's Ranch
with pedophiles and toe what I'm so
sorry that we didn't get bat into the
week but we had AP here and we got to
talk about the clan boy and we made
memes don't forget to go to imgflip.com
and get you some free memes just hack it
it's it's a five finger discount over
there on memes and make sure you go to
the Tony michaels.com don't forget to go
to the Tony michaels.com and sign up for
the Discord server it's free it doesn't
cost you a single thing to go to the
Discord server okay and that's where you
could share memes grab memes if you
don't want to make your own we'll have
videos there for you we're going to be
dropping them in if you find videos on
the Internet or if you find Clips
anywhere drop the link we'll try to pull
the video we'll try to make it to where
we can drop the video in the chat so you
guys can have it the spread around like
herpes all over the Internet we got such
we Skip's making such great videos
dererk is taking videos making such
great clips and I think we should share
them with all of you to share around the
[__] all around the internet to save
our democracy have a great weekend don't
do anything I would do or do everything
I would do you know to be quite honest
same time sa place on Monday serf up
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events in
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow toning
on social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after
me [__] them [__]
[Music]
them Murphy's mebn head ass
speaking don't you Des to me in that SI
balloons are flying theing at record of
the Year S&P and NASDAQ closing at
session High balloons are flying the Dow
closing at its eighth record of the Year
S&P and NASDAQ closing at session
High